Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today we are going to see how we can use our
hands, but not our fingers to mingle with
objects in virtual worlds.
The promise of virtual reality, VR is indeed
truly incredible.
If one day it comes to fruition, doctors could
be trained to perform surgery in a virtual
environment, expose astronauts to virtual
zero-gravity simulations, work together with
telepresence applications, you name it.
The dream is getting closer and closer, but
something is still missing!
For instance, this previous work uses a learning-based
algorithm to teach a head-mounted camera to
tell the orientation of our hands at all times.
One more paper down the line, this technique
appeared that can deal with examples with
challenging hand-hand interactions, deformations,
lots of self-contact and self-occlusion.
This was absolutely amazing, because these
are not gloves.
No-no.
This is the reconstruction of the hand by
the algorithm.
Absolutely amazing.
However, it is slow, and mingling with other
objects is still, quite limited.
So, what is missing?
What is left to be done here?
So, let’s have a look at today’s paper
and find out together.
This is its output…yes, mingling that looks
very natural.
But, what is so interesting here?
The interesting part is that it has realistic
finger movements.
Well, that means, that it just reads the data
from sensors on the fingers, right?
Now, hold on to your papers, and we’ll find
out once we look at the input…oh my!
Is this really true?
No sensors on the fingers anywhere!
What kind of black magic is this?
And with that, we can now make the most important
observation in the paper: it reads information
from only the wrist and the objects in the
hand.
Look, the sensors are on these gloves, but
none are on the fingers.
Once again: the sensors have no idea what
we are doing with our fingers, it only reads
the movement of our wrist and the object,
and all the finger movement is synthesized
by it automatically.
Whoa!
And, with this, we can not only have a virtual
version of our hand, but we can also manipulate
virtual objects with very few sensor readings.
The rest is up to the AI to synthesize.
This means that we can have a drink with a
friend online, use a virtual hammer to, depending
on our mood, fix or destroy virtual objects.
This is very challenging because the finger
movements have to follow the geometry of the
object.
Look, here, the same hand is holding different
objects, and the AI knows how to synthesize
the appropriate finger movements for both
of them.
This is especially apparent when we change
the scale of the object.
You see, the small one requires small and
precise finger movements to turn around, these
are motions that need to be completely re-synthesized
for the bigger objects.
So cool.
And now comes the key - so, does this only
work on objects that it has been trained on?
No, not at all!
For instance, the method has not seen this
kind of teapot before, and still, it knows
how to use its handle, and now to hold it
from the bottom too, even if both of these
parts look different.
Be careful though, who knows, maybe virtual
teapots can get hot too!
What’s more, it also handles the independent
movement of the left and right hands.
Now, how fast is all this?
Can we have coffee together in virtual reality?
Yes, absolutely!
All this runs in close to real time!
There is a tiny bit of delay though, but,
a result like this is already amazing, and
this is typically the kind of thing that can
be fixed one more paper down the line.
However, not even this technique is perfect.
It still might miss small features on an object.
For instance, a very thin handle might confuse
it.
Or, if it has an inaccurate reading of the
hand pose and distances, this might happen.
But for now, having a virtual coffee together…yes
please, sign me up!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!